hi friends my guest this week is
Professor Brian Keating and he almost
won the Nobel Prize and today we're
going to find out just what it feels
like to lose it it's a really cool story
he set up the bicep2 telescope in
Antarctica and it looked like him and
his colleagues had made a unique
discovery and there was a roller coaster
of what actually happened and some
disputes about the data and what it
showed there's politics from the Nobel
Prize Association and I didn't
understand what it was or how it works
how its chosen and what the process is
and the heritage of this particular
organization are but we're gonna find
all of that out today it's a very
interesting story albeit at the expense
of Professor Keating but if you enjoy
this episode go back and check out the
ones with Sabina Hassan Felder and
professor Adam Frank they're both
fantastic physicists and they have a lot
to add to this discussion about the
politics of science obviously if you
love the episode please share it it
makes me very happy but for now let's
welcome professor Keating oh yeah
PS I've cited shortened down the intros
to these podcasts because I respect your
time and I found myself skipping through
a lot of the introductions to podcasts
that I listen to as well in future I'm
going to endeavor to keep them around
about one minute I think this should be
enough time to tell you about the guests
and inform you of any upcoming
announcements which are important but if
you feel like you need to know more or
less if you want me to chop it down even
further and just say hi friends then let
me know actress will X on all social
media
[Music]
professor Bryan Keating how are you
today I'm fantastic Chris thanks for
having me on it's an absolute pleasure
so what are we gonna learn about today
well you know I kind of sought out your
podcast
I don't know how usual that is but I
heard my friend Mario Livio
on your show about two months ago a
month and a half ago and the interview
that you did was was phenomenal and of
course he's such an engaging and erudite
fellow that I felt like it would be a
good opportunity for me to share some of
the ideas that I've been thinking about
in my work as a cosmologists as I point
out I don't do hair and nails but a lot
of people think I I do until they meet
me nor do I tell horoscopes but but
instead what I look for is really the
earliest evidence for the beginning of
the universe and what I thought is so
interesting about the perspective that
colleagues such as myself can provide in
Contra distinction to those of you know
these are unite brilliant folks you've
had on like Mario is that I'm an
experimentalist so an experimentalist as
a cosmologists it doesn't mean that we
build universes we've got a healthy ego
but not quite that healthy lets us think
that I could actually build a universe
but instead we build telescopes that
will allow us hopefully to reveal the
earliest evidence for what's known as
the Big Bang and how we came to know
what the universe is comprised of along
the way may hopefully be revealed
through the types of telescopes that
myself and my colleagues built and this
is very different from those of the
professions you know as practiced by
your your you know late countrymen and
my distant late colleague Stephen
Hawking or or Sir Roger Penrose who
recently visited me in San Diego and was
part of our podcasts that we run for the
arthur c clarke center here in san diego
and that was that is you know to study
the universe from a purely theoretical
point of view is absolutely necessary
and i always say you know some of my
best friends are theoretical physicists
but but in reality we
we have learned much more about the
universe from people that build
instruments whether it be Galileo or
Newton or you know people that that are
connected deeply to instrumentation
because there are very few theories in
the world if you think about it there
philosophically there can only be so
many different descriptions of how then
the actual world works many fewer than
how possible worlds could work and I'll
give you one example and maybe we'll
talk about that at greater length today
for for those in the audience who may
have heard of something called the
multiverse this is a very controversial
subject within physics and even
philosophy and it really revolves around
the notion of whether our universe is
alone whether ours is the only universe
both that exists now or may have ever
existed or may will ever exist in a
distant future and that's quite an
astounding thing to think about it's
motivated in some sense from the thought
of people like Copernicus and Galileo
who showed the earth is just but one of
many planets in the solar system now we
know there's but one of the Milky Way is
but one of many galaxies in the universe
so perhaps it's it's natural to think
maybe we're just the not just the only
universe in what's called the multiverse
so these are the kind of things we study
but but in in contrast to many other you
know kind of more popular maybe much
smarter they're better speakers they're
not mine than I am but these these folks
that study things from a purely
theoretical perspective it's just a
different perspective I thought it would
be great for your audience to get a
taste them I couldn't agree more
how different is the or how bipartisan
is the world of physics when it comes to
the experimentalists versus the
theoretical lists yeah the theoreticians
that's right yeah the recession's Wow
yeah it's kind of like you know
Republicans and Democrats or easily we
never know it's it's much healthier than
that I would say it's it's like it's
it's much less of a rivalry than any
sports team is like the offensive team
and the defensive team of American
football yeah except you know I wouldn't
want to wager on you know the
theoreticians I know to be very good
football don't you let it that out I
think no I think I think Mario I
wouldn't back going up against Mario
Livio he seems like he's probably good a
bit of a streak to money needs to get
going he's got a massive size indeed the
other there there there is a I would say
a healthy rivalry as there should be so
it used to be I don't know how it is in
the UK whether your football teams there
but in America there used to be laws in
unofficial laws within sports teams for
our version of football that if you were
playing against yeah you know an
opposing team in American football you
weren't allowed to socialize with them
the night before the game like they're
called anti fraternization laws like
well that's not really very friendly you
know that's not very gentlemanly yeah
but of course you know if our version of
football yeah we wear helmets and you
guys in rugby and kind of you know it's
different that way but but there was a
rivalry and you want to stoke that
competition and that those juices
because it was thought that competition
would be compromised if they were too
friendly and you know I just you know
contrast that to the word fraternization
means fraternal I have three brothers of
my own and I don't think we'd ever
characterize our relationship you know
as very you know friendly and in a
competition even even a physical one so
so perhaps that's miss name but I think
there should be a skepticism
you know it's very easy to write papers
and conjecture marvellous things like
wormholes and extra dimensions and the
multi-verse and things like that it's
it's it's easy in some sense of course
intellectually it's very challenging to
actually be able to back that up but
it's it's sort of you when there's no
when there's nothing no skin in the game
as Nicholas Taleb says you know there's
nothing really that they're not going to
go out there and build the experiment to
detect it and that's very different than
the way things used to be right Galileo
had have an idea that following NASA's
you know the
celebrate or accelerate towards the
earth at the same rate regardless of
their mass or composition and and he
showed that and he built an apparatus
allegedly the Leaning Tower of Pisa etc
but he did other things that we know are
not apocryphal a Newton built telescopes
and he built he built other apparatus he
was of course an alchemist and you know
he was actually involved in the
day-to-day events of the world but and
even Einstein had patents which is quite
amazing to think about and and of course
you know the great physicists of the
20th and 21st century many of them you
know had equal facility with experiment
in theory and I think that's the nature
of a well-rounded Renaissance man or
woman physicist that we should aspire to
be capable of forays into both the
purely abstruse theoretical domain and
what it actually takes to have skin in
the game to go out and measure it and so
I get that completely is it it seems
like the sky's the limit really or
actually no because that's probably a
poor term to use in your fieldwork right
for the something is the limit for
theoretical physicists as you've said
they can if they can postulate it and
back it up with an existing theory which
again can also be based on something
which hasn't been shown to be true in
experiment but perhaps make sense
mathematically given the constants that
we know about the universe etc etc that
they can say it and put it forward and
downstream from that there's actually no
real implications other than oh wow you
wrote a really cool theory about this
particular thing let's run with it and
see if anyone else fancies backing it up
it's right yeah exactly so it's a kind
of view and this may be your listeners
and maybe you'll appreciate the analogy
it's kind of like I feel we as
experimentalist are the bouncers in the
nightclub of the universe and that we
actually are the ones that that squash
and keep things out and keep the field
honest in the sense and and it can also
happen to us as I described in my book
so my book is called losing the Nobel
Prize and it's a story it's really kind
of like the dirty laundry or
confidential you know kind of tell all
about what it's like to be a
professional scientist in this current
era and that also means that sometimes
you get swept up in sort of the pursuit
of things that are non-scientific in
nature and that they may be related to
benefiting your career or your
pocketbook or what-have-you and this is
a relatively new affliction you know I
don't think very many people in the
olden days were concerned as much about
fame and fortune in science and it's
certainly true that you know Einstein
didn't die a billionaire right I mean he
his ideas in some sense were responsible
for a lot of the technology from GPS to
the laser and he made some money but it
wasn't formed but if you look at how
much he could have contributed
intellectually versus monetarily it's
vastly outweighed so I think that it's
important as I say in my book you know
we can write a book about the multiverse
or the wormhole or the black hole or but
you can't really put it on the cover of
the book whereas the every single book
comes with a dust jacket right and and
what does it do its keep dust out I mean
I always hated dust jackets and I was
thought they were useless and they'd get
in the way of the book but now I
realized that they serve this vital
purpose which is to keep the dust out of
the story
and the story in my case is intricately
dependent on the role that dust in the
cosmos this in this case plays and so I
say to my friend you know try getting a
wormhole jacket on the cover and I'll be
very impressed so losing the Nobel Prize
tell us why does the book begin what's
the story so it's really a three-part
story one part is a memoir of what it's
like to be a cosmologists to work with
some of the biggest minds intellects and
egos in the world at the cutting edge of
astronomical discovery in this case we
built the telescope that we put at the
very bottom of the world at a location
called the South Pole which is the sort
of central part of the Antarctic
continent reached for the second time in
1912 by one of your countrymen Robert
Falcon Scott he famously arrived there
just three weeks later than his
Norwegian counterpart Roald Amundsen
that three-week delay ended up costing
him and five of his of his employees if
he will their lives and I draw some
parallels between the quest to conquer
Antarctica and the South Pole in
particular and the quest to be the first
in science to make a discovery to make a
discovery that is as as is important as
is foundational and as is important
career wise to its discoverers as the
finding of the South Pole was or the
landing on the moon in the 1960s was for
America
so that's part one it was like to be a
scientist at the bleeding edge of
competition collaboration and in some
cases controversy is there not very many
bits of low-hanging fruit you've said
it's kind of like a winner-take-all
competition here and you know if you
want to be the first person to reach a
pole in the world you've only got two
choices right like you're gonna that's
it once one's gone there's only one left
and once that one right you fall you
know is it similarly is it kind of
needles in a haystack so to speak in
terms of finding like the big winners
well you know there's a famous quote by
John Archibald wheeler who was you know
Fineman when a fineman's advisors and
and so forth but that was you know our
job is to expand the island of knowledge
into the sea of ignorance something to
that effect but when you make an island
bigger you're also making the coastline
between the border between ignorance and
knowledge bigger and elongated as well
so I think that's sort of the job there
it's harder and harder to find new
frontiers that certainly true but
there's so many mysteries there's so
many things that are there staring us
right in the face that we know nothing
about that some have decried the
stagnation in cosmology and physics in
particular and really this glorification
of the past is a symptom of the of the
relative back water stagnation that's
occurring within physics today
namely that there haven't been according
to a German physicists of being Haas and
Felder make a good guess someday for you
as well
or let it run but you have okay another
ano
gonna ask whether or not you'd heard it
but yeah we we had a discussion I was
gonna bring up I was gonna mention some
of that with you as well so we'll get
into that in a second what would really
that was the quote that you had from her
well it's really just the claim from her
that there there haven't been any
developments in nearly 50 years that
rivaled the developments of say the
preceding 50 years in physics and that
is you know and that is kind of
depressing on one hand but I know that
she's a theoretician she's not an
experimentalist and that's why I think
it's it's so exciting to be someone who
can build interact and acquire data from
these sentinels whether they be located
underground in space at the South Pole
in the Atacama Desert in Chile I think
it's the most exciting time in history
from that perspective so I don't
disagree with her that you know she may
have chosen poorly in her field choice
now we have a friendly kind of rivalry
she's a she's a she's a certain
contrarian and so what I really feel is
that the couldn't be more stark the
contrast and the kind of ebullience and
excitement that I feel every day getting
to do what I do versus kind of the
depression and and sullenness that I see
for my theory theoretical colleagues so
I'm always trying to convert them you
know get them there get the aisle yeah
exactly get them on the other side of
the team so what's what spot to part two
is really a story of how we came to know
what we know about cosmology so a
history of the universe from the first
telescope ever used in astronomy by
Galileo up through the bicep2 telescope
which is a telescope that I conceived of
and helped to build at the South Pole
Antarctica that seemed to provide
evidence for what was claimed to be the
biggest discovery of all time the day we
made the announcement and certain to
rack up numerous Nobel prizes for those
of us potentially who built the
instrument and certainly for the
theoreticians who made the predictions
and how did the you know the
inflationary universe that I described
how did that come to be and whatever its
implications as I said the multiverse is
a natural extension it's a consequence
according to the founders of inflation
without without the inflation
universe you know being true there would
be no multiverse and and only if there
is inflation can there be a multiverse
in many of these theories so it's
incredibly high stakes for cosmology and
for philosophy and all of physics that
we get this right and our experiment
claimed evidence for this back in 2014
to global headlines and fanfare Nobel
Prize whispers we later how to retract
that statement that claim and what that
experience was like as a physicist and
as a human being I think you know when
you interview these brilliant people
I think the layperson is most interested
in what are they like as a person like
you know what was Einstein like as a
father that's something I was always
interested me like what was you know
Fineman like as as a friend those are
more interesting like I can learn the
physics the physics is sort of immutable
it's it's like you know it's it's it's
it's it's possible to learn the physics
out knowing the the personality behind
it but that's why these biographies of
Einstein and and fine men that keep
coming now it's like how many
biographies can you have you know it's
like did he have a secret double yah
clone somewhere I think if anyone was
gonna have a double or triple or
quadruple life it would be Richard
Feynman that's the discussion I had with
Mario Livio I think as close as Mario
Livio can have a man crush on someone I
think richard fineman just about might
be it what what super interesting he
said that talking as a perfect
representative of the lay person when it
comes to physics I hadn't taken a
massive interest in Isaac Newton until I
found out about all of his very strange
quirks and beliefs and how he used to
love to go to hangings and he kind of
had a little bit of a sadistic side to
him and he spent more than half his
career trying to prove a bunch of
theological stuff to be true and you
know and I'm like oh I'm like [ __ ]
gravity like I want to know about what I
want to know about like his weird quirks
and ah right
did you know like not human eyes yeah
totally right did you did you never hear
what he claimed is his greatest
accomplishment for the man who came up
with calculus the law of universal
gravitation Udonis he that he died a
virgin that I remember hearing that
this is great because it was as close as
he could get to emulating Jesus Christ
and it shows you the esteem with which
he held now I'm not for you know
deconstructing just to tear somebody
down you know like George Washington
wasn't great because he had slave Nam
that's although I do kind of deconstruct
the nobel institution in the book and
that's the third part of the book has
what does it mean because what what I'm
happening was I I was you know we made
this announcement I had kind of been
edged out in a dramatic series of events
from the you know basically denied the
paternity of the experiment that I
helped the sire so let's just dance just
roll roll back a tiny a little bit so
we've got near the bicep2 telescope yeah
but first off why is it called the bicep
telescope why is it bicep at all so the
the inflationary universe predicts that
if inflation took place the universe
would be suffuse with what's known as
gravitational waves these are waves of
the gravitational force field so as they
pass by a person say if that was
possible to imagine the person would
gain and lose weight alternatively as
the wave propagates by so it changed the
force in which gravity is pulling on you
obviously on earth they wouldn't make
any big difference but but say for in
interstellar space and you know
potentially this is a thought experiment
you could do now you know that these
gravitational waves were first detected
directly in 2015
resulting in the LIGO that experiment
leadership or at least three of the four
people that did it
and winning the Nobel Prize it's a
problem that we can talk about and then
that was for the coalescence of two
black holes of the mass each one about
thirty times the mass of the Sun they
came together and made a black hole that
was slightly less massive than a black
hole with the mass of fifty nine solar
masses say so one entire mass was
converted to gravitational energy it
couldn't be converted to light these
black holes by virtue of their intense
gravity are black and so they coalesce
they gave off by Einstein's equation
equals MC squared they converted one
solar mass worth of mass now you know
their their gravitational binding energy
into pure gravitational wave energy
that if you can imagine all the mass in
the universe not just 30 mass black hole
30 solar mass black holes every black
hole every galaxy every person there
every single plant everything in the
universe exploding forth not just over
the course of a second as these black
holes call us but over the course of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second how violent that
process would be that create waves of
gravitational energy those waves would
travel at the speed of light and they
would influence the oldest light that we
know to exist in the universe and that's
called the cosmic microwave background
radiation it's a type of microwave
energy radio energy that comes to us in
all directions that energy would be
twisted and curled in a certain way that
I described in the book with about 60
illustrations custom-made for the book
and that twisting curling pattern was
known as b-mode polarization or curl
pattern polarization and so when I made
up the acronym bicep I wanted to reflect
that we're trying to muscle our way back
to the beginning of time and get the
jump on these curls so the bicep does
the curling on your body that's the
origin of the name so it's such a good
name that's again it's a very clever way
to do and this jimbros up and down the
country that are applauding you for
coming up as well so we we've got the
telescope I'm going to imagine it must
have been an absolutely massive
undertaking to be able to to come up
with something like that and it's in the
most inhospitable climate on the planet
that is the most remote with the least
supplies and all the rest of it so what
was the process like of actually
creating it so creating it you know I
always say was less difficult than
actually you know like coming up with
the idea was harder than actually
building the thing because is that a
reflection of the theoretical versus
experimental debate again yeah it's very
hard to convince other people what a
great genius you are you know so but it
turns out you need to in order to have
they wherewithal financial and the most
valuable capital human capital and
getting young people to believe in your
ideas and to follow you literally to the
ends of the earth as they did and then
to actually
build the instrument you know is an
engineering challenge but it's not an
insurmountable one now I I say so with a
little bit of glibness but in truth I
have to give credit to these hard
extremely hard-working people in the
field like my students and my
collaborators all around the world
because this telescope was actually able
to be cooled down to a temperature
that's 10 times lower than the
temperature of interstellar space which
is just unfathomable so a quarter of a
degree above absolute zero so if you
could cool something down to absolute
zero all of its motion all the chemicals
all the molecules would stop completely
stopped dead and perhaps if there's no
motion there's no time right so time is
really measured by the reckoning between
successive events well nothing's moving
no time could elapsed and that's deeply
connected with this theory of inflation
so how do you go from non universe to
universe you know it's kind of a big
mystery right it's like going from
non-life like just chemicals pouring
chemicals together getting something
living and so for me to go from non
experiment to experiment although that's
the zero to one moment in Peter Thiel's
language I know you like him you know
going to that to that extreme is is very
difficult but it's not as hard as
getting all the assets together like a
military campaign to the bottom of the
world so that took four or five years to
do then by nature of the faintness of
the signal we had to observe for for a
total of between the two experiments
that I was a part of that made this
announcement possible six years of
observations and then another four years
of data analysis on supercomputers you
know just running non-stop the biggest
most massive computers on earth and that
and then 50 people working you know at
some funds day and night around the
clock
to make this announcement that we had
seen the spark that ignited the very big
bang that we believe exists today so you
saw the six years of capture were done
then further four years of processing
and at the end of that what what
happened because someone someone at some
point has come into the room and said
something like professor gating I think
we found it
like that that point must have occurred
can you can you talk us through that
yeah so that's the that's one of the
ironies of the book and one of the
things I think the book does a job a
good job at attempting to describe is
how human scientists are so what you
just described is is the confirmation of
the theory right you said someone can we
think we found it so that's like Eureka
what does Eureka mean when Archimedes
would say Eureka I found it so to find
something means you were looking for
something right unless you just like I
saw so like that's weird
and that happens a lot in science too
and I argue in the book that's the
purest form of scientific discovery when
it's serendipitous like the deep deep
fields image right yeah there's this big
blank space we just go opens yeah our
closer to where you are now Jocelyn Bell
discovering pulsars for the first time
completely accidentally she wasn't
looking for pulsars it just showed up in
her data and she did the hard work to
unravel it and eventually a Nobel Prize
was awarded for her work but not to her
to her male advisors as I point out in
the book but exactly so there's
serendipitous discoveries those are pure
those cannot be found and they're also
not susceptible to what's known as
confirmation bias if you have some idea
about me or you know you're what you're
bouncing at a club or so you have to
have some notion about you know what's
desirable or what you're what you're
looking for but in science we like to
think that scientists are complete
dispassionate but what if there are
non-scientific forces at work such as
you know people like me at the time I
was really obsessed with the Nobel Prize
and winning it and and and being
elevated to this very very tiny pantheon
of scientists or household names that
that was so enticing it really dominated
a lot of my early career mental energy
and so when we yes we did discover the
signal that I knew if correct even when
I came up with the idea for the
experiment would be the biggest you know
homerun or what he call it century
hitting a century I don't know and
cricket the the idea of doing that was
so intoxicating to both discover the
purity of the scientific quest but also
being honest to win a Nobel Prize when
we did that of course then we just
basically you know looked in as many
places as we could to see if we were
right
and it kept coming up that we were and
and but but the farther we went down the
more committed to the hypothesis
confirmation we were as well and then
the ultimate revelation was done not in
a peer-reviewed journal article as
typically required as the gold standard
of scientific discovery but only since
the late 1800s by the way but
nevertheless that that discovery was
announced you know at a press conference
held at Harvard University on March 17
2014
- as I said worldwide fanfare with Nobel
laureates in the audience and and other
Nobel laureates speaking to those Nobel
you know potential Nobel laureates
speaking to those past Nobel laureates
and I wasn't at that event and and the
the feeling of you know creating
something being a part of something only
to see sort of the control taken away
from me that is a big element of the
book and furthermore the the the quest
that drives many scientists you know I
say not all scientists suffer from the
same malady that I did but many of us do
be you know just listening and the few
podcasts that you've done with scientist
and and and they're fantastic
you know the word Nobel Prize comes up
off a lot and it's sort of a way of
subconsciously perhaps acknowledging
this authority bias that human beings
have that we want to have experts to
listen to we want to offload the
responsibility of thinking for ourselves
just honest we want to trust that
Einstein knew better than us so he won
the Nobel Prize and he came up with the
photon and special relativity so I'm
gonna listen to him about world
government being the ideal situation and
you know I don't know how you feel about
that but I think you are totally right
we sometimes affords we're for
particularly intellectual thinkers an
almost universal level of admiration
which you know Sir Isaac Newton there we
go like fantastic like listen to him
about physics probably don't listen to
him about what you should do with you
Sunday afternoon like exactly yeah it's
called the halo effect it's called the
halo effect people want to believe that
there'll be people you know so in
America every four years we get this
list of of Nobel laureates that say you
know which democrat you should have
never seen them once say they should
vote for a Republican now you can say
whatever you want about Republicans or
Democrats but you know if it's
scientific there should be at least like
one who would be enough you know it's
how it's hard to believe this the
groupthink is so pretty but it is and
though it's totally totally is this was
the the I'll give you the 30-second
synopsis to my podcast with Sabina
for anyone who is listening if you go
back to being a Hassan Felder the beauty
in physics I think it was called the
episode and the the bottom line the
punchline of the whole thing was that I
had discovered during the podcast that
physicists were people too and I always
presumed that they were these input
process output robotic kind of Paragons
of perfect intellectual pureness and and
it turns out that it's just it's just as
political if not more political than you
so many you know it made me feel like my
job which is manipulating social
networks to get people to go to
nightclubs almost felt like relatively
it kind of Noble and then on the flip
side there's all of the you got to be in
this right camp you got to be you can't
be backstabbing this person or you
you've added your self to this
particular kind of theory that means you
can't be in this and I couldn't I
couldn't believe just how bipartisan and
try parties of him all the rest of it it
was it blew me away it really is and
it's a way of just oversimplification
which is a natural human urge and it
just proves yeah that that humans a
scientist are human and I think the
cliche the trope that we were just
walking Wikipedia's is is really
nonsensical and I do my best to you know
display the humanity of a scientist by
both making many many mistakes every day
you can answer my wife about that but
also you know having a having a real
clear-cut you know kind of image of what
is what is important about science so if
you look at science the word science in
Greek roughly translates into knowledge
but that's very different than wisdom as
I always point out to my colleagues you
know just cuz you're a scientist it has
nothing to say whatsoever about your
wisdom I mean it's so won a Nobel
laureate he was actually here at Saint
UC San Diego where I am I said if you
think that Nobel laureates are so
brilliant you should see them in the
morning of the event when they're trying
to find where the eggs are served you
know which is you know another cliche
but at the same time you know again I
don't problems with the with the Nobel
laureates who win I have an issue with
this with the with this process with
this establishment which like what
Sabina talks about both of our books
have a similarity in that we're taking
on these sacred cows and sacred cows are
not always you know deserving of that
stature and I think in the case of the
Nobel Prize is held to such high esteem
that one should be careful about the
outsized influence that it has on
scientists certainly but especially on
non scientists members of the public key
members of your audience when they hear
Nobel Prize they're just gonna stop
thinking are they like I'll listen to
what he and it's mostly men by the way
which is already a tip-off that there's
something rotten in Stockholm right I
mean you know there's many anyone who
thinks that women aren't as bright as
men you know so why is it true that that
only you know 1% of all winners of the
Nobel Prize in Physics and chemistry are
women there's something obviously at
work that's systemic that needs to be
changed and yet the noble institution is
incredibly ossified and and really
susceptible in my mind to vast
Reformation that they're very unwilling
to to do and can you take us through the
what the Nobel Prizes because you know
the term of the Nobel Prize I know it
and again I am mr. avatar for the
layperson so you know I know that the
Nobel Prize is given in a number of
different categories I know that it's
maybe once every year or once every
couple years and I know that lots of
Jewish people win it like yeah those are
those are kind if that's the beginning
in the end of my knowledge you don't
know why it exists I don't know where it
started I don't know who looks after I
don't know what the process is or
whatever it is so yeah give us give us
the cliff notes on what the Nobel Prizes
so my book begins with the story of how
Alfred Nobel's
younger brother blew himself up and it's
kind of weird like what does it have to
do with cosmology so Alfred Nobel was a
was a Swedish actually Russian Swedish
and inventor and entrepreneur who is the
son of a father who had invented some
military applications for high
explosives in the 1850s in in Sweden and
had mainly been selling them to the to
the Russian Empire for their many wars
that they were conducting in that time
period but the goal of having a stable
form of nitroglycerin which is very very
powerful explosive but also very
mercurial and explosive that dangerous
that was a goal of many many inventors
that would be the killer app that could
be used to safely do construction if
could be invented so Alfred Nobel's
younger brother so he was one of seven
kids I believe Alfred and three or four
of them died before they were 22 years
old mostly by you know natural causes
but in the case of his younger brother
he was experimenting with this compound
nitroglycerine and he dropped a vial of
it and it blew up the laboratory in
Stockholm where he was working in the
family laboratory killed about four
other people that were his lab
assistants and that really drove a
manual no bail that the Nobel brothers
father insane and he ended up giving
control of the company to one of his
other brothers and one thing led to
another but Alfred went off on this
quest single-minded focus to find to
find it a safe version of nitroglycerine
and he invented it and it made him
perhaps one of the richest people of the
world at that time in today's dollars
worth you know billions of dollars and
in this company still bears his name
exists which is what's amazing there are
very few companies you know that are
based on an invention by an inventor
from the from the 19th century that
still have that name that still exists
maybe ten of them around the world in
this case it made him incredibly wealthy
but it was still tied to the manufacture
and sales of arms between you know
different countries in Europe that were
continually at war with one another and
then also dynamite in pallasite and all
sorts of other military
core tight explosives used to kill
people and one day about 20 years after
he invented dynamite alfred was walking
around the streets of paris france and
he came upon a headline and said Alfred
Nobel the merchant of death has dead and
the man who had killed more people in
history than any other person has met
his own just reward they were kind of
gleefully celebrating his death and it
was very shocking to him it must have
felt like you know Evan easer Scrooge or
you know somebody like really
celebrating their death and it shocked
him so much that he resolved to use his
vast personal fortune after he died to
endow a will which would give out prizes
in five categories literature medicine
physics chemistry and peace and so peace
kind of one that stands out but all five
of these awards and they've since
enlarge that to include economics about
80 years after he died and they're given
out annually and what Alfred wanted and
he said explicitly in his will which
confined the Nobel Committee on the
Nobel Prize website to this day he said
I want these prizes to go to the person
in the singular who created the most
important or beneficial discovery or
invention in the preceding year that has
had the biggest benefit on mankind so
there are three stipulations a single
person would win it for an invention
made last year and that had the greatest
benefit on mankind now unless your
theoretical particle physicist I don't
know how much the Higgs boson improves
your daily life or benefits your daily
life you know if you if you do then you
know please consult a psychiatrist but
because you know it's really not that
relevant to our daily lives it's very
important in the grand scheme of the
universe but it would it would exist
whether we discovered it or not unlike
say the x-ray which was the subject of
the first Nobel Prize in 1901 which is
improved and better the lives of human
beings is that what got the first Nobel
Prize yeah so I talk about that it's a
pretty cool pretty sort of big big
impact
yes covery right absolutely and there's
been other ones and so so I plan on the
book because what happened was as I said
cuz I I
is you know created this experiment
which was immediately claimed to be know
about worthy the day of the announcement
in 2014 I wasn't you weren't there for
which what that which you weren't there
for you want that I was not there for
yes I talk about that a very very honest
in the book about you know my my four
balls and faults in the whole affair but
but in truth you know I think it ended
up being that there were competitions
and there were discussions and polls on
the internet and papers published you
know that really claimed that of all the
you know kind of people on earth I might
have a decent shot you know better than
one in five or something of winning a
Nobel Prize which is pretty high you
know K there's you know billions of
people on earth right and and you know
how often do you get to be in that very
select group and then as I described in
the book it was not to be obviously the
title would be different if I had won
the Nobel Prize not one stood so the
tide of losing the Nobel Prize but it
has two different meanings one of the
meanings is how I personally lost it and
lost out on this opportunity
although creating something Nobel worthy
and then having that slip away I
describe the emotions of that and the
personal side of that but also the
cosmic side of it what does it mean to
talk about things like the multi-verse
and like the inflationary universe and
the creation of of the Big Bang what
does that mean in a world in a universe
that's polluted with contamination and
with confirmation bias and with all
these other foibles that human beings
have so that's one aspect of the title
but then if you can imagine this you
know so imagine whether there's a Prince
Harry you know he and Princess Megan you
know they want to come to a club and
you're at that club and they're about to
come into your club and you hooked it up
they're just so you're just gonna love
it gonna take selfies with it and then
right before they get there they say you
know what we're not gonna come to your
club or any or clubs in fact could you
recommend a better club for us to go to
better than any of the ones here so what
ended up happening was not only did I
lose the Nobel Prize chance that I you
know best chance I would ever have but
that same year that I potentially could
have won it I was asked by the Swedish
royal academy of sciences to nominate
the winners of the Nobel Prize that you
know I would have
had my experiment not been disconfirmed
and our results retracted Oh claim our
claim of discovery retract the
experiment was correct
it still is correct we still believe
it's true but the interpretation of what
we saw has been changed radically from
detecting the imprimatur of God if you
like or of the Big Bang of nature to the
most humble substance in the universe
this cosmic dust that I described at
some length in the book I was gonna say
what's the specifics about because
you've gone from you were there you
would at the finish line
ready to go but it seems like there's
kind of two elements to this story one
of them is the potentially systemic more
political the side that I want to hear a
little bit more about how the Nobel
Prize is judged and stuff like that but
the obviously the sort of meat and
veggie of it is the fact that what you
found was interpreted differently to
what you originally thought is that
correct can you take us through that
yeah so when we set out to measure the
universe as early as light and this
curling twisting pattern that gaves
bicep it's named etc the the experiment
was designed to see in effect and theirs
is designed to see this leftover
aftershock of the Big Bang via
gravitational waves and so it wasn't
designed to necessarily rule out every
other potential source of cosmic mimicry
so there could be sources that we did
know about say the earth emits a type of
signal that could be mistaken for it so
we designed the experiment to block out
the signal from the earth because we had
a located at the South Pole on earth now
similarly say the atmosphere could do it
or there could be emission from sources
that are not cosmological but they are
in the in the solar system or in the
galaxy and we knew about those sources
and we did our best to eliminate them
but there was one source that we simply
did not have enough information and
there was one group of astronomers that
had this information in fact they were
led from the European Space Agency it
was a satellite called the Planck
satellite and they had measured the sky
and they we knew that they had
information which could tell us
if we had seen cosmic dust which are
particles grains of carbon nickel iron
particles left over from the previous
explosion of a generation of stars
called the supernovae that may have
existed that did exist in our galaxy
prior to our solar system's existence
and other solar systems existence and
without such supernovae we would
probably not exist because the iron in
your blood the hemoglobin molecule that
carries iron molecules iron atoms that
was forged as iron molecules were forged
in the core of a supernova that exploded
in our local stellar neighborhood 4.9
billion years ago so you literally as
Carl Sagan used to say you know have
star dust falling through your blood
very poetically but it also flows
through the galaxy and because it's made
of iron
just like the filings as Michael Faraday
showed and another showed they align
themselves in magnetic fields or our
Milky Way galaxy has a magnetic field
too and it can produce the exact same
curling twisting pattern of microwaves
as the Big Bang's
inflationary epoch could so that was the
signal that we mistook and the reason
that we didn't have access to
information which would have
disconfirmed our claim earlier is
because it was held by our competitors
the Planck satellite did not want to
share this information with us we didn't
know if they had detected it as well as
we had and wanted to scoop us out of
this discovery and potentially win their
own Nobel Prize or they didn't have a
good understanding yet of their own
deficiencies so forth with their
instrument and it turned out to probably
be a little of both but there's this
incredible competition that exists
within science to get there not only get
there first but to just obliterate the
competent like leave no doubt that you
made this definitive measurement we
wanted that to be clear throughout the
entire paper press conference everything
we did that there should be no doubt
that what we discovered was what we
claimed and in the end the results were
correct but we made a very exquisite
measurement of the emission from dust
particles in our in our local galactic
neighborhood incredibly challenging by
the way because the signals that we saw
were just a few parts in a billion out
of the temperature of the South Poles
exquisite technology I described how
exciting it is this technology and how
it's progressing and will progress based
on the lessons learned from bicep2 to
build a next generation of
instrumentation and such as the Simon's
Observatory which is a big project that
I am leader leading here in San Diego
around the bay start with institutions
around the world literally 250
researchers on every continent you know
currently on the planet which is amazing
to think about so the the real discovery
and in its aftermath and how it affected
me and the field personally is really
tied up in this quest at least
personally for me with the Nobel Prize
and I came to see it in a sense as
almost a false idol and I came to see
the Nobel Prize in a sense as a religion
as a type of religion ironically
practiced by mostly secular scientists
right 70 percent of our National Academy
of Sciences declare themselves to be
atheist agnostic with atheist and and
yet the their if you go to any website
you know that supports science or any
Discovery where you know the the upper
echelon of authority need to be
referenced and even in Sabinas books and
she's not you know really beholden to
the no but she you know constantly is
interviewing Nobel laureates and talking
about things that were award with the
Nobel Prize and saying well nothing's
been awarded the Nobel Prize and you
know in theoretical physics shows you
how you know how poor these predictions
as a scorecard as a talisman as an icon
and I and I make these parallels between
a religion and the Nobel Prize and I
think you know they're they're quite you
know I think that the nobody really
disputes it which is kind of interesting
to me
nobody disagrees with the Reformation so
I present five ways to improve the Nobel
Prize before it's too late
because I think if you have an
institution that refuses to change its
operating you know mode that it's at
risk of catastrophic you know kind of
existential crisis well it loses it
loses its purity right like the whole
point again for me as someone who
doesn't know what he's talking about
the the one of the only things that I
want the Nobel Prize to do is for it to
go the right path
yeah do you know so more people right
your people I want it I want to get on
to what the process for the Nobel Prize
consists of but just the final thing
that I want to kind of round off the
story for you personally was how did you
find out about the fact that there had
been this particular change in how your
how your discovery had been viewed and
then what was the next sort of the next
couple of days like I'm fascinated to
hear what that what that means to
someone who's pushed so hard and and
come so close yeah yeah it was it was a
mixture of emotions you know first
obviously embarrassment a little
personal sense of humiliation that you
know I had kind of gone along with this
result even though I had some doubts
about it we all had doubts but but
certainly I had voiced a lot of doubts
and you know a little bit of gratitude
that you know I had had not been you
know so publicly associated with the
face of this detection because I had
been kind of eliminated which which I've
described in the book and how this role
I wasn't eliminated completely obviously
but but the way the announcement was
made I was you know prevented from being
a part of it so bizarrely the thing the
thing that you felt a little bit maybe
jilted at you kind of been left at the
altar so to speak when it came to the
glory but in a roundabout fashion that
had also protected you from being the
figurehead who upon whose shoulders most
of the the backlash should had landed I
suppose that's right exactly right and
yeah so you know I just admit that you
know how it felt I wasn't you know glad
I wanted us to be right and I want us to
be right even if I didn't win the Nobel
Prize but you know in the end the day
Newmont of the story for me became a
recognition that as I said ironically
all these scientists are atheist but
they worshiped this golden crucifix of
an icon the Nobel Prize which literally
has a graven image you know a picture of
Alfred Nobel on it and you bow down to
it on the day he was he died and in
December 10th of December 10th 1896
that's what the day that they're awarded
on his birth
they and and for me this this kind of
religion no longer holds the idolatrous
trance fiction that it had once before
and that it it no longer really consumes
my my daily life in any way other than
you know to think that the privilege of
getting paid to do the research that I
get to do and work with the genius
people students and other scientists
around the world and I get to work with
that is reward enough and when we make
the Nobel Prize this paragon of
scientific excellence we are kind of
reducing ourselves sorry to say you know
to kind of like entertainers in the
Hollywood Oscars like Pop Idol or
x-factor right yeah exactly exactly and
and and for us I think you know
scientists should be the most immune
from that right aren't we supposed to be
hyper rational and these Paragons of
intellectual honesty but I think you
know we're human beings and the problem
is that you know I as I often say I did
an interview with Scott Eastwood who's
you know Clint Eastwood's son very
famous podcaster here in the in the
States and you know I was saying like
well you don't really expect you know a
movie studio doesn't really expect that
all of its films are gonna win Academy
Awards I mean some of them you know are
gonna be like The Fast and the Furious
and they're just not where he's like I
was in the Fast & Furious I was a
highlight of my podcasting career but
but you know but he's he agree with me
you know it's like the the actors and
actresses who go into Hollywood they
don't go into it saying oh I'm only a
good actor if I went in a ball prize but
or an Oscar either but the studio's you
better believe they want most of their
pictures to get that's why they have
tending globe nomination and Tom the or
write all these things sundance and
they're all about giving each other
awards and there is no second there is
no Golden Globes or sag
comparison you know second and runner-up
for the noble prop there's just nothing
like that so it puts the Nobel Prize
under great scrutiny and holds it up to
this level of of really austere of being
you know just the augustness of winning
it
I think that it does a detriment has a
detrimental effect on scientists but to
the extent that's gonna survive
I wanted to preserve the purity of it by
making certain Reformation zai talked
about as they say five of the ways that
you could do it
one of us has been invited to nominate
winners of the Nobel Prize and coming
upon it you know as a scholar would so I
received a letter a couple of weeks
after we made you know the final nail in
the coffin for our detection back in
2014 and I got a letter from the Royal
Swedish Academy which said you know do
not talk strictly confidential that's I
guarantee it's the last time I'll be
asked to nominate winners no but but it
said you know here's what you need to do
look for the multiple winners you know
who deserved the prize
it could be something done decades
earlier and it could and it didn't
mention anything about having a benefit
on mankind I said Alfred only said three
things in as well it has to go to one
person in the preceding year who had the
greatest benefit and here they are
asking me to do nothing of what he asked
me to do and I felt like well that's
kind of one of the worst things you
could do is not is not have respect for
the wishes of a dead man right a dead
man has one chance of one will and
imagine you know you know you're gonna
live you know a hundred more years or
whatever but you write your will some
day and you say I want all the money to
go to Oxfam or or whatever and they give
it to like you know whatever I don't
even know what they give it to but they
give it or you know Greenpeace and they
give it to Exxon Mobil or BP you know
you'd be pretty pissed off but what
could you do nothing absolutely nothing
cuz you're dead and and so I felt like
it's become it's be it's incumbent upon
scientists like me to advocate for
change from within and I don't have any
you know illusion delusion that they're
gonna listen to me but I felt the story
was too important to ignore and so far
I've gotten great feedback from people
around the world scientists and
laypeople about what it's like to really
aspire to this and and to really make
great important discoveries but not
judge your salt on whether or not this
you know three inch diameter gold you
know medallion like a rap star would
wear you know goes around your neck I
could see I could have seen you in that
rafter on your neck which is a shame but
there's a couple of things
a couple of things have been thinking
about as you've been speaking that one
of them the first thing that you said
was that the humiliation maybe came a
little bit higher than the
disappointment and some listeners of the
show will know that I came off a
motorbike in Bali a couple of years ago
and I'm driving along now driving a 50
pence per day Balinese moped which is
map that was my first error the second
error is not really being very good at
riding a motorbike and a truck pulls out
in front of me and I come off the bike
anyway and I'm wearing a tiny pair of
swim shorts and a little vest and I just
it's me versus Balinese Road and it
winds all day like I've got kind of like
second-degree burns on half of my body
and most of the left hand side of me is
stuck in the Balinese tarmac which is
very caught it's perfect for removing
skin we breathe cheese grater and the
first thing that I felt so I was riding
with these two Aussie guys who I'd made
friends with while I was out there I was
travelling on my own I'd made friends of
these 2 Aussie guys and they kinda knew
me and I kind of knew them beforehand
but anyway we relatively new friends and
I was in mortal danger
I just injured myself like the forefront
of my mind should have been my injury
and the first thing that I felt when I
stood myself up and brushed bits of
tarmac out of me was embarrassment the
the ahead of Abraham Maslow's hierarchy
of needs I forget the fact about like
I'm worried about I'm injured or is this
gonna scar or uh you know ever is it
another car coming is there gonna be
another car behind me that hits me no no
I wanted to stand up and think oh you
[ __ ] like that and I it's just so
telling of the fact that we are no
matter how as you say these sort of
Paragons of beautiful intellectual truth
and purity and all the rest of this
stuff it's born out of a flawed system
and that system is human and the other
thing is that I think is is really super
interesting is this that the journey
that it's allowed you to go on which i
think is a lot of a lot of people will
be able to draw a comparison with which
is kind of that of
discovering that the the process of what
you have created that life is a process
of becoming not being and that as you've
gone along the way you're now able to
look back on it and say well you know
like the fact that I was able to bring
all of these people together and in a
very bizarre way I wonder whether or not
you would have the same level of nuanced
and subtle appreciation for all of the
different elements if it was
overshadowed by a large award I don't
know whether you'd be able to look back
with the same degree of high fidelity
that granular kind of yeah absolutely no
I agree with you hundred percent I mean
I always joke you know people say oh
you're a hypocrite you wouldn't turn a
nobel prize down if you want I say well
you want to see how if I'm sincere just
get them to award me the Nobel Prize you
know as you know I feel like yeah it's
almost a blessing because it's sort of
like a liberation yeah I don't know if
you're married or whatever but I always
say you know when I met my wife I I got
to stop like going on dates like I never
have to have a first date again you know
hopefully yeah it's very liberating when
you when you free your mind of it and so
when I freed my mind of obsession about
I was told to get tenure to get a high
level of promotion at the University of
California I have to win a Nobel Prize
I've been told by many people that
they're basically judged in their
careers on their prospects of winning a
Nobel Prize to be liberated from that
and say like well you know that is that
is completely an asinine metric by which
to judge a human being and I say in the
book you know the journey is more
important than the gilded destination
and you know we make fun of like you
know I don't know if you you know
whatever how biblical you want to get
but you know back in the Bible it talks
about the Israelites worshiping a golden
calf you know this this icon made of
gold that they made themselves you know
a few weeks after witnessing God
allegedly you know wipe out Egypt with
all these plagues right and I thought
that's so silly but but in truth you
know 3,000 years later here we are doing
the exact same thing we worship a golden
icon with a picture of Alfred Nobel and
that is part of the way that we value
our self-worth I think that's a shame in
a modern scientific society to feel that
way and so I feel like it's part of my
you know one of the lessons learned and
how to handle it's not just about you
know losing a Nobel Prize which you know
probably all of your listeners can
sympathize with but how do you handle
not winning you know top 50 podcast or
how do you fan or not not you know
getting to you know big high school
class president these are all things
that peak you know you're far more
likely not to get into your own personal
promise length and then to get in it and
that's okay right you're not gonna get
in to be Manchester United or new cat
what it is your team Newcastle the good
better so you know from my perspective
so how do you handle that because that's
the state if you look at the probability
distribution of what you're gonna spend
your life being it's not being a Nobel
Prize winner it's not being burritos it
comes exactly one not gun exactly so I
hope that people you know will enjoy the
the journey and not fixate on the
destination let's hope the journey is a
lot more successful than your Balinese
motorcycle journey nice I think it's
it's super super interesting to speak to
yourself especially after having spoken
to Sabina and to hear just how folly
some of the elements of science are and
you know the something that was super
interesting that we kind of moved past
was when you had the European Space
Agency and they didn't supply you with
the particular types of information that
you needed that would have helped you
further your research and you think like
I think from my side things like physics
especially when we're talking about
making developments and learning about
the universe is the same as medicine in
that the goal should be as wide and as
vast progression as expedited as is
possible but you that's not what happens
it becomes narrow and deep because
there's certain information that will
benefit one particular group and over
another and etc etc and I don't know I
think removing ego from the situation is
is going to be impossible and you can't
litigate for it
you know you're not gonna be able to
have someone coming in and say on you
need to
share your research with these people or
whatever and as well we can talk all we
want and the listeners will be in the
midst once we are broadcast you'll be in
the midst of some very mindful other
guests that we've had Rick Hansen and
and Corey Allen and all these meditation
experts you know to detach from the ego
and all this sort of stuff but yeah on
the flip sides like telling someone
who's won something fantastic like yeah
man like you should have never even gone
for that in the first place you should
detach from your ego you let no [ __ ] off
like I worked really really hard for
this and I hear one that got it and
because that story's newsworthy and all
the ones of the runners-up aren't you
inherently you inevitably end up with
this asymmetry of glorification yeah but
exactly who is going to advocate for
reform right there there are people that
win it have a vested interest in it you
know I note that there have been
peacemakers who turn down the Nobel
Peace Prize right oh yeah I want to I
want to ask out what what does the peace
what do you make your Peace Prize how
does that work what you have to do I
mean some of it's been you know it's
it's one of the few prizes that anybody
can nominate anybody for so you could
nominate me I could nominate you that's
where as the yeah yeah but the physics
prize you have to be invited one of the
criterion to be invited is that you want
to know about prize that's one option so
the rich get richer if you want to know
about prize your graduate student and
postdoc is much more likely to get a
Nobel Prize or conversely if you work
for somebody you're likely to go so I go
through all these kind of different
machinations within it but you know I
think like there there is sort of a
vested interest in keeping look the
Nobel Prize is a monopoly it's the most
prestigious award of its kind just like
the Oscars are monopoly yeah there are
other runners-up but it's it's pretty
head and shoulders above them right but
the noble part there is no real
secondary competitor to it I mean I
challenge you know people to know about
it and so as such it has a huge
responsibility to inform the public
about how science is actually done now
described in the book some of the cruel
aspects of the Nobel Prize we're in you
know people that you know mostly women
but but sometimes men as well including
just a year the two years ago when one
of you know Scotland's greatest
scientist around Reaver
was basically written out of history
because he happened to die you know six
months before the Nobel Prize for LIGO
was awarded and it's all part of these
crazy rules that they like to adhere to
that they themselves choose and pick
what to apply as I say they don't follow
what Alfred wanted so I hope your
listeners get a chance to engage with it
I welcome we have a couple websites we
set up one is just called losing the
Nobel Prize calm where people can
suggest winners and put a petition kind
of like the moveon.org strategy and then
I have a mailing list on my website
Bryan Keating calm that that people can
engage with I love hearing from people
how it's affected them and it's it's
it's gotten a lot of good attention I
used to think well you know I shouldn't
even care about like whether it wins
these awards for best books of the year
but you just roll it straight back in
again I did like the stoic anymore - I'm
too fortunate no it's it's really it's a
receive a lot of lovely attention yeah
and so yeah I'm really sure to hear what
you think about it and I think it was
really a really really am I think the
mind you sure and I'm looking forward to
finding out the sordid details about
what goes on behind the scenes and stuff
like that so yeah it's it's been a blast
thank you so much for coming on I really
appreciate your time thank you so much
and let's keep in touch Chris I
certainly will do links to everything
will be in the show notes below please
make sure that you follow Bryan online
he has a very interesting Twitter feed
and his website will be linked below so
man thank you catch that on thank you so
much Chris
[Music]
you